J'ai besoin d'un bébé, je ne vois tout simplement pas pourquoi je
devrais attendre mon père, peut-être que je n'ai
jamais été dans une relation sérieuse
qui a duré plus de six mois.
ce ne sera pas difficile parce que ça va
être [ __ ] de difficile mais j'admire ton
courage et j'aime les bébés je n'aime tout simplement
pas laisser mon destin au destin
est-ce que tu vas bien je suis amoureux de toi et je
ne veux pas  être marié à George il
voulait plus rendre votre livre enlever vos
vêtements
5 4 3 2 1 8 juin ici votre horoscope
non il est totalement égocentrique de tout ce que je
fais chaque chose pratique c'est
dommage que vous ne puissiez pas le rendre à  son
ex-femme eh bien, il est évident que vous
réfléchissez tellement avec un hélicoptère, d'accord, mais il
pourrait y avoir une opportunité de vous réunir tous les deux
, alors partez.
être humain oui ce
serait un tel gâchis je veux dire
toi